Let's start with a simple scatter plot. Each dot
in this chart represents the winning percentage of the Boston
Red Sox in the year between 1960 and 2010. In
this chart, the main visual cue that we're using is
position. The year for our particular winning percentage is dictated
by where we are in the x coordinate. And we
see what the winning percentage is by looking at a
data point's position on the y-axis. Secondly, we can note
that this plot provides pretty good context. We
have an X labeled Year, indicating what the x-axis
represents. A Y labelled Winning Percentage, telling us what
the y-axis represents. And we have a pretty descriptive
title. Boston Red Sox Winning Percentage. We might
include by year to make it even better. This
will help people who are unfamiliar with this data
really look at this chart and understand what's happening.
But as you can see, a scatter plot here really puts focus on the individual
values. It's a little bit hard to discern trends. It could also be hard for a
reader to mentally fill in the gaps between
the points and really understand what's happening from
year to year. It's for this reason that we might want to use a line chart.